this is something that drives me so
crazy
about the media coverage of trump what
do you hear donald trump could give the
most wonderful hopeful
sunny speech in the world and actually
he did give one of those
in south dakota at mount rushmore and
the media said it was
dark and divisive trump he's pessimistic
he's
dark he's angry no president trump is
the sunniest politician of my lifetime
probably the only sunnier politician in
recent memory was ronald reagan
who would say america's best days lie
ahead
and then you have joe biden who says
america's darkest days lie ahead
everyone says trump is fear-mongering
trump isn't fear-mongering at all
trump says we're gonna find solutions
don't live in fear of the virus
joe biden is the one fear-mongering
and he's doing it for a couple of
reasons one because
if he gets to the white house he will
institute some draconian policies for
some short period of time
and then he'll claim credit for having
cured the virus
even though he doesn't deserve any
credit for that because we already got
the cure before joe biden
became frankly we got it before even the
election but they announced it a week
after the election
we already know all of this but he'll he
would claim credit for it and
two because it's a a way to
amass more power and that's what these
politicians have been pulling the whole
time so if america's darkest days lie
ahead
how are we going to get through those
dark days a lot of people have been out
of work at this point what 11 months
congress sent them 1200 maybe people got
1200
earlier doesn't get you very far well
now
we've got a wonderful major important
stimulus
covid relief plan congress is going to
send some of you
600 for being out of work 11 months and
nancy pelosi says
this is very significant we also
have in the legislation direct payments
which were not in the republican bill
to america's working families i would
like them
bigger but they are significant
and they will be going out soon
very significant now look
pelosi she wishes it could have been
bigger how big is this relief bill going
to be it's going to be like a trillion
dollars and there's another trillion
some odd dollars
added on with all sorts of foreign aid
and all sorts of payoffs to political
cronies
but you know unfortunately all congress
could find with 600 measly dollars
for the inconvenience of destroying your
livelihoods for the past
year significant
is 600 significant i don't think so when
we're talking about keeping you out of
work for an entire year
nancy pelosi wouldn't think so too if it
were politically convenient for her to
say what you really thought because i
remember two years ago
do you remember this two years ago
president trump passes this
tax bill this tax reform bill and nancy
pelosi comes out
and says this bill is terrible you know
it gives
tax breaks to zillionaires and
corporations
and that wasn't true the tax bill also
gave about a thousand dollars in relief
to individuals and you know nancy
pelosi's thousand dollars who needs a
thousand dollars
that ain't nothing but crumbs the
in terms of the bonus that corporate
america received
versus the crumbs that they are giving
to workers to kind of put the schmooze
on is so pathetic
it's so pathetic it is pathetic i hate
to say that i agree with nancy pelosi
two years ago
but i do agree with nancy pelosi two
years ago by the way
at the time in terms of a tax bill
that's a pretty good break
but we are now in this unprecedented
moment
where these politicians for their own
political ends can't forget it was an
election year
decided to shut down the country destroy
people's lives
even before the the coronavirus gave
them the excuse to do this
you had prominent left-wingers guys like
bill maher who said we need a recession
we need a recession i know it'll hurt
some people
but we need it because that's the only
way that we can get trump out
so and and frankly the left did more
than give us a recession
the left shut down the country
for a year and then the way they're
going to make it up to us is
600 no i can't tell you how many
letters i've seen tweets posts
all over the place from people who say i
lost my savings
i lost my business my family is really
struggling
and you can take your six hundred
dollars and shove it i don't want it
it's just not enough i would i would
much rather and i think
a lot of people feel this way not get
the six hundred dollars
right now even if even if a lot of
people need it and i know a lot of
people who need it
better to knock at the 600 than to go
along with this outrageous
offensive bill that is going to indebt
generations
after us first of all because of these
ridiculous spending projects
and that is frankly such a slap in the
face
these these elite politicians in dc
members of both parties more than
democrats but some republicans too
saying oh the oh the plebeians they're
they're they're complaining again give
them 600
600 what does that come out it comes out
to about six bucks a day
since they shut down the country that's
adding it on to the 1200
that we got early on six bucks a day not
worth it not going to make a difference
they need to veto this bill very
fortunately president trump has
intimated
that he will veto this bill he's just
going to stop it
right in its tracks president trump
comes out yesterday over the protests of
his advisers
over the protests of republican
leadership in the congress
republican leadership in the senate and
he says
this bill is outrageous and
not good enough for me i'm also asking
congress to immediately get rid of the
wasteful and unnecessary items
from this legislation and to send me a
suitable bill
or else the next administration will
have to deliver a coveted relief package
and maybe that administration will be me
and we will get it done thank you very
much
so president trump goes in and
i love that he's not giving up hope by
the way absolutely love that
he goes in and he describes what is
going on in this covid relief bill
the 900 billion dollar package provides
hardworking taxpayers
with only six hundred dollars each in
relief payments
and not enough money is given to small
businesses
and in particular restaurants whose
owners have suffered so grievously
they were only given a deduction but two
years is not acceptable it's not enough
congress found plenty of money for
foreign countries lobbyists and special
interests
while sending the bare minimum to the
american people
who need it it wasn't their fault it was
china's fault not their fault i am
asking congress to amend this bill and
increase the ridiculously low
six hundred dollars to two thousand
dollars or
four thousand dollars for a couple
love that absolutely my man let's do it
what you're going to hear
from a lot of left wingers now is wait a
second i
i thought republicans were concerned
about spending too much money
we don't want to spend money on your
stupid investments which are really just
payoffs to the liberal institutions we
don't want to spend a bunch of money
to study shrimp running on treadmills we
don't want to spend a bunch of money on
all of that nonsense but we do want to
spend money
when you are insisting that americans
not work for a year
so he says this is not going to work
i am demanding that you increase this
number from 600 to 2000.
all of his advisors around him were
saying no come on that's not how it's
done
you should have said this earlier when
the republicans were negotiating
i don't care about the republican
leadership in the house and and
in the senate what have they done for us
lately
the one good thing i'll say about
republican leadership in the senate
they've given us a lot of judges
not that it's mattered a whole lot but
it's something but for the rest i don't
care good send them back
as president trump says this could be
the
problem for the future administration
but he is not going to put his name on
this trash
and then he comes in and says that
the next administration might be him i
love that
thank you some fight some spine he
doesn't have to give this thing up until
january 20th maybe there will be some
deus ex kraken that comes in before then
you know just that
kraken we were promised maybe something
happens but even if not
trump is going to keep on fighting he's
going to keep acting as the president of
the united states
until the very end i do hope the next
administration is his
because joe biden is a liar
and a crook joe biden
is going out from the office of the
president-elect
and he's giving his sort of silly press
conferences to these fawning reporters
and then occasionally you'll get a
reporter who doesn't just give him
everything he wants
peter ducey from fox news asks joe biden
if the allegations against his son
hunter are russian disinformation
and joe biden oh he laughs and laughs
though
of course those alligators are
completely ridiculous it's all
vladimir putin merry christmas
everybody thank you
do you still think that the stories from
the fall
about your son hunter were rushing his
information
campaign yes yes yes
god love you man you're a one-horse
opponent
i'll tell you thank you thank you
i promise you my justice department will
be totally on its own making his
judgments about how they should proceed
thank you first question
what is a one horse pony
is that is there any relation between
the one horse pony
presumably a pony that only rides on one
horse
and a dog-faced pony soldier
usually a dog-faced pony soldier could
get on a one-trick pony but i've never
heard of a one-horse pony before guess
joe got a little confused
how strange huh also also
the hunter biden allegations which big
tech in the mainstream media
spent weeks actively suppressing in a
an unprecedented way on big tech they
wouldn't even let you message
the new york post article discussing
those allegations out
then later on they said oh look at these
allegations gosh what could those be
those allegations cannot be russian
disinformation
because hunter biden already confirmed
the allegations
he already confirmed that there is an
investigation
into his finances at the federal level
he can
the the investigation into his finances
has been going on before bill barr even
got to the doj
this is another great example where the
biden family needs to get
on the same page with regard to their
lies because
hunter biden comes out says i never
talked to my dad
about my no i'm sorry joe biden comes
out first he says
i never talk to hunter about hunter's
business dealings
then hunter goes and gives an interview
to a magazine and later to television
and said yeah i talked to my dad about
the business dealings
and he said i better know what i'm doing
and then you can actually on the tv
interview
you see hunter biden realize that he
wasn't supposed to say that he goes i
mean but yeah but i didn't we didn't
talk there was no conversation
no conversation and then thankfully the
interviewer actually said
hold on you just told me there was a
conversation he goes yeah well okay that
was it though but that was the only
conversation
so they're not on the same page now we
know joe biden
absolutely 100 knew about hunter biden's
business dealings
well same thing here hunter biden's
acknowledging
the investigation joe biden probably
should
too joe biden has been lying
for his entire political career he
dropped out of the 1988 race because he
lied and plagiarized
he's been lying about really serious
things for a long time
another one of these projections they
always say trump's the big liar trump
trump doesn't lie about it trump
exaggerates his crowd sizes the way that
new yorkers talk
okay the way that every single person
that i know in new york
they get sometimes they get a little uh
they like to embellish their stories a
little bit but it's not a lie
joe biden saying yeah my son hunter's
crimes or russian disinformation that's
a lie that lie matters
that's the liberal establishment for you